[SOUND] That was beautiful.
>> That was tiring.
>> It was tiring.
That was a very long,
long, long flashback.
>> It was like two whole
lessons of flashback.
>> Two whole lessons of flashback,
hence Game Theory III.
>> All right, well now that we're back.
[LAUGH] Is there anything left to say or
do we basically cover everything?
>> Well, I think we covered
almost everything, but
if you recall from
the flashback there were two or
three things we said were probably
best left for another day.
>> Yeah.
>> And
it turns out that today is another day.
>> Not according to that video, right.
If they watch that video now,
then today is that day.
>> Every single person who
watch those videos had to take
several days to do it.
>> All right, that's fair.
>> At least emotionally, so
I'm going to claim it's another day.
And so we're going to talk about three
things that we said that we wanted to
talk about before.
In particular, we're going to
talk about solution concepts.
And we're going to spend a little bit
of time talking about mechanism design.
>> Neat.
>> So, let's start with some
solution concepts.